normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government tweet
from Ben Shapiro who says Candice if you
feel that taking money from the daily
wire somehow comes between you and God
by all means quit and that is a bold
response to Candace owens's tweet which
is my understanding is a Bible verse but
jamus might be better versed with this
she uh kandace someone tweeted blessed
are the peacemakers for they shall be
called the children of God blessed are
they which are persecuted for righteous
righteousness' sake for theirs is the
Kingdom of Heaven blessed are ye when
men shall revile you and persecute you
and shall say all manner of evil against
you falsely for my sake no one can serve
two masters either you will hate the one
and love the other or you will be
devoted to one and despise the other you
cannot serve both God and money in
response to this Ben said by all means
quit to which Candice replied you have
you have been acting unprofessional and
emotionally unhinged for weeks now and
we have all had to sit back and allow it
and have all tried to exercise exceeding
understanding for your raw emotion but
you cross a certain line when you come
for scripture and read yourself into it
I will not tolerate it so needless to
say things are getting rather
interesting and if you're wondering why
they're fighting what this all about it
has to do with Israel Palestine recently
Ben Shapiro was seen on video saying
that Candace Owens faux sophistication
was disgraceful as it pertained to what
was going on and Candace Owens has a
video where she made she said that her
point was simply why are we so concerned
about what's going on in Israel when our
own universities are teaching children
at young people to demonize white people
why are we spending so much money and
energy on foreign countries when we
should be securing our borders and
helping the American people and I I'm
like yeah I I agree with Candace on that
for that Candace tweets this blessed are
the peacemakers which is to imply
perhaps ceasefire and that's what a lot
of people are reading into it Ben of
course has just haltered to quit and now
we've got uh I think I actually have
this tweet from Mike cernovich let's see
if I can uh pull this up Mike cernovich
uh well we've got a couple actually
here's Tucker Carlson and where's the
Mike cernovich one okay I guess I might
not have it but Mike cernovich said it
was constructive termination which is
basically when you create a a pressure
in your company that is so they're going
to have to quit a single instance can do
this Jack bovic says Candace Owens
Compares Ben to a BLM activist who
accuses someone of being racist if they
don't support defunding the police and
Mike cernovich said he's become
indistinguishable from a far leftwing
identity politics woke psycho he's
working the soft cancel culture Angle
now I didn't fire Candace she quit but
he should also look up what constructive
termination is so uh let's just get into
it I don't know this is the big story
how you guys doing anybody I mean why
don't we have any fun drama I don't
understand anybody that go like as far
as like C covich's uh covic orov
whatever uh his criticism um anyone that
touches on identity politics starts to
sound like the people you know whether
they intend to or not they're going to
sound like they're diving into identity
politics whether it be you know white
people talking about their whiteness or
or whatever or if you're complaining
about white people and whiteness or
whatever anytime you touch that you you
can't help but sound like the people
that are like leftists yeah like like
you're leftists like you're a victim
like you you need some kind of special
accommodation because people are
offending you for talking about that and
it doesn't matter who does it it doesn't
matter whether it's a person a white
person a black person it doesn't matter
that's just the way you come off when
you when you go into that area I got an
issue what I I wouldn't describe as a
hard journalistic correction but a
failed um what's the right right word in
a failed Insight on my part I said the
other day that Candace and Ben arguing
over this stuff and having a kind of a
public spat is just good for the daily
wire it's press attention which is true
and that it probably wouldn't go beyond
this they're going to criticize each
other and then but now Ben's telling her
to quit with which I don't know if like
if you guys have uh legal expertise to
some degree but it seems to me that if
you have a contract with someone and
then you publicly say you should quit
you've just given them legal recourse to
terminate their contract you know I
think what's going on here is that um
daily wire is a
fom and they like to have kind of a
stable of people in their team but who
are completely under their thumb uh
remember the Crowder business which
happened not that long ago and I thought
it was so odd because what would appear
to be a private negotiation suddenly
erupts into public well why well
apparently what Crowder was was kind of
um balking against was the idea of quote
being owned by the daily wire right and
and I think this is what's going on here
is that Candace is a very independent
Spirit she's actually got a pretty good
ego she wants to be her own person and
yet somehow she's coralled into the
daily wire stable and they expect her to
quote behave and she doesn't really
think she needs to she's Candice she
doesn't need to she doesn't need to and
so I see this as a kind of I mean you
could have had the philosophical debate
without this acrimony so it's very
interesting that the two have become
conflated but do you think Ben Shapiro
could have had the philosophical debate
without the emotion behind it because
it's so much tied to his core ident and
how he views the world maybe Candace
could have because she's a little bit
more removed but someone who's tied to
the religious and ethnic groups that are
involved it's it's much harder well I
think that is right I mean I do think
that this is the make or break issue for
Ben I think it is the lens through which
other issues are filtered uh and also
even if you take a position that said
something like you know uh this is
anti-israel but it's not necessarily
anti-Semitism boom you've like violated
the taboo you're like suddenly on the
outs so I think this is a case where in
Daily wire a relative lock step is being
demanded uh and Candice just won't play
along with that and so you've got this
public spat um and I assume this happens
at all major media companies right I'm
sure fox has had the same issues as it's
grown there are some people who feel as
though they can't question their boss on
on certain issues well I mean the thing
about it is
you know you want to be clear in advance
about what you stand for so if daily wi
basically say listen we want a variety
of views but kind of no variety on this
one topic this is kind of a a bright
line for us then you wouldn't join daily
wire if you intended to step out a line
but it looks to me like what happened
with daily wire was that they were like
let's get some really big personalities
into our tent um and and even the phrase
that was used in the context of crowder
wage slavery which is kind of an old
phrase out of Marx in the 19th century
that's what really rankled Crowder
because he's like you know I'm not going
to be your slave you know you might pay
me well but nevertheless I'm still my
own man and I think something I I hear
the same Echo here I got to I got to I
got to tell you man you know when the
Crowder thing went down I brought up how
we had negotiations with the guys at the
daily wire and I think they're fantastic
the the negotiations and the
conversations that I had with co-ceo
Jeremy boring were probably the most
refreshing business negotiations I've
ever had in any circumstance where I
felt like he wasn't lying to me and I
respect that tremendously I'm not
kidding man when I've met with these big
podcast companies back like several
years ago when I've met with uh big
corporate news they're they're blown
smoke up your you get what I'm saying I
sit down with Jeremy and it was like a
real conversation about what's going on
what we could do why we could do it and
you know what It ultimately came down to
is uh I don't know that I could do a
deal like this because I'm kind of a
crazy guy and I might want to buy a
billboard that says you know Liz Cheney
is a fat pig or something like that and
they chuckled and they were like Fair
Point Fair Point you know and so I don't
know if I mentioned that before I think
I did because I was like I would like to
insult people like warmongers who I
greatly despise you know I do get a lot
of people saying no they'll never come
on your show Tim don't you get it and
I'm like well you know I guess as if
like Liz Cheney was going to come do
timcast and subject herself to a
two-hour interview where she was asked
tough questions about the things she's
been involved with was ever going to
happen so but BS comes down to this like
I saw this outright when I sit down with
them and they're like what what are What
are the potentials that we have cuz
they're like we love what you do and
then I was like and I'm a fan of what
the daily wire does especially in the
culture war and then ultimately it came
down to one simple question of obviously
like money plays a role but daily wire
is is flush with cash but the the real
issue is look man I'm going to take my
money and I'm going do weird things with
it I'm I'm going to do uh uh uh I want I
want to culture Jam I want to I want to
shock the system I want to say things
that are offensive and they were like
fair point then you know we'll we'll
work on things but we'll keep it we'll
we'll keep it professional I said cool I
mean whenever you're an instit tion of
any kind you're subject to the
institution its investors its donors I
mean I've been at the American
Enterprise Institute the Hoover
institution it always occurred to me
that I have a measure of Independence
because when you're in a think tank
basically they pay you to do whatever
you want toes write books give speeches
and so I was like this is the best gig
ever but I realized well how ises AI
funded well they're funded by
corporations they're funded by a handful
of big donors you you can't run a to
those guys because then there's someone
to complain to and if you become a
liability they're going to offload you I
I do want to mention because you know I
see like super chats where they're
saying I'm with Candace on this one I'm
I'm like that's the beauty of the daily
wire though they've got you choosing
sides the daily wire or the daily wire
unless of course Candace does quit and
and and that would be I think that would
be like a nuclear bomb going off for the
daily wire if Candace actually leaves
I'm hoping that this is just like kind
of a half-thought stunt of some sort
like Candace really isn't that Will
Smith you mean you think it's a it's a
variation of the Hollywood uh production
yep like you know who did Will Smith SLA
was it Chris Rock Chris Rock but then it
turns out he wasn't even with his wife J
J right came out was like we've been
separated for 100 years yeah that's so
gross that just makes the whole thing
worse I mean I think the this fight or
this dispute online is going to be
something Progressive media Outlets try
and sorry Serge uh Progressive media
Outlets try and capitalize on as look
these right-wing Enterprises are are
fracturing they're falling apart to
direct from the fact that they also have
a lot of issues yeah the the the Israeli
Palestine conflict is is splitting both
the left and the right and really making
people pick sides I imagine that Candice
doesn't have a strong I imagine it would
make sense to think that Candace doesn't
have as strong of an opinion as as Ben
obviously because Ben's got family in
Israel you know so she's she could have
a strong opinion that America shouldn't
spend money on Foreign Wars yeah but
think that I think Ben looks at the
whole thing as beyond that we're living
in a time and this is not the way things
used to be but where institutions tend
to be defined by one guy uh even if you
go back to the Old National Review was
Bill Buckley a lot of other guys around
him but like it's Buckley's magazine
commentary was Norman port's magazine
and uh you know this is the tempul
operation it's really more the Sheamus
operation yeah not a lot of people know
that I got this a media and so I think
what happens at Daily wire is it is Ben
Shapiro but then you've got these other
guys who are kind of luminaries in their
own right and so now the issue of is a
little unclear who's the brand but you
know it's really simple actually if you
look at all of their personalities
they're homegrown but Candace Owens was
recruited Candace Owens was already big
was already popular was already uh
moving politically like in and Jordan
Peterson actually well right right right
right yeah so but you you know like uh
nolles and claven these are their
homegrown personalities that they've
built up Matt Walsh and they've done a
tremendous job in in in getting
attention and building influence for
their for their hosts but uh was Michael
nolles worked for the company and then
you know has now become one of the
biggest social social and political
commentators well I I kind of want to
touch on something that you mentioned
earlier denes you said that the daily
wire grabs different people so that they
can have a large tent reach a broad
audience and have a lot of different
influencers I think that's true and I
think interestingly enough that's
actually symbolic of a broader issue
with the conservative movement which is
we've tried to welcome everybody into
the tent and we actually don't have
principles or know how to define
ourselves anymore as a result of that so
when it comes to the Israel Palestine
conflict obviously that's something
where I think there can be diversity of
opinion but there are so many social
issues issues like abortion
homosexuality um lgbtq issues more
broadly speaking where the right doesn't
even know what it believes because we've
expanded the tent out to everybody who
the Le has said they don't like and so
we've actually allowed our enemies to
decide what our movement is I don't
disagree with that but I think generally
American American culture is very
ambiguous we don't have a defined
cultural identity that people
theoretically could assimilate to so it
becomes difficult to say where any lines
are and then you add policy on top of
that you don't think America had like a
broad overarching culture I think we
could and we did at one point but I
think as it stands right now Americans
are very resistant to cultivating
American culture I mean think about
everyone who was like if Trump gets
elected I will move to Canada like
there's all kinds of resistance to being
American if that's how our young people
feel then we have failed as a culture to
maintain a cultural identity young
people in the United States a lot of the
people that I end up working with when
I'm like touring and stuff like that
younger people really don't they want to
avoid the Nationalist uh idea and that
comes or just patriotism well that
that's what they they see patriotism as
nationalism they see American flags and
they are they're turned off by and some
people that I'm really really close to
and that that I have a really great
relationship with they don't see a a a
love of country as something that's
important they think of themselves as
Global and I do understand that that's a
little bit more of the that is that is
probably because of the people that I'm
around they they travel around the world
they're they're you know playing
concerts and and performing in places
all over the world so that does make
people feel less connected to a an
individual place but it is something
that is that is true among younger
people in the United States and I think
that it's partially because we've we
have between the Gen X and and possibly
the Millennials they didn't instill a
pride in young people and they didn't
really you know Civics was taken out of
school and stuff and people don't
understand why America is special and
what about our government system is
special and why it's why it should be
preserved and you you add to that that
the younger Generations I mean the
millennial generation my generation and
gen Z and gen Alpha are growing up in a
world where everything is being handed
to you and I don't mean everything but
you're Bare Necessities now I get it
expanding beyond that is becoming
increasingly difficult owning a home is
becoming increasingly difficult but when
your whole life is playing with your
friends going to school coming home and
eating Rice Krispy squares or whatever
and Tang from your mom and it's not
having to chop wood otherwise you're
freeze to death in the winter we are we
are building multiple generations of
people who don't know what it takes to
survive and that breeds entitlement and
resentment and without any any sense of
community it's that's antifa it's chaos
it's the far left it's the woke cult
well I think we've also manufactured
quite a lot of C uh cynicism some
intentionally and some otherwise so just
to speak to my own experience people in
my generation can probably relate to
this I was 6 or 911 happened and
immediately there were just American
flags everywhere everyone was talking
about patriotism and coming together as
a country and then what that was used
for was basically to push for these wars
that basically everybody now looks back
on and says were bad for the country so
for a lot of people in my demographic
their first introduction to patriotism
and to love of country was abused in
such a way to give handouts to the
industrial military complex and do
things that ultimately were not good for
the country so people are less willing
to come on board with common projects
that actually are good for the nation I
that's not new I mean young people young
people being disillusioned with America
uh and the flag and not being patriotic
it's it's not really that new I mean
we're J xers and we were raised in the
80s and we had Ronald Reagan and I think
we were raised in a certain era of
Greater patriotism but there still was a
big contingent who thought that Ronald
Reagan was more evil than the Soviet
Union I they really did so so this is I
mean it has to be put in cont down you
well because yeah and I mean I think
Academia and I mean desesa wrote the
book on it a liberal education was one
of the first books that opened my eyes
about what they're indoctrinating kids
with and now when you have your own
children in college you really see it
but I I do think things need to be put
put in context a little because what
they said about Trump they said about
Ronald Reagan you know there was a
window where W Bush was a hero and then
all of a sudden you know he's we had the
Vietnam War and there was a massive
young people's revolt against that and
then Reagan came along and and Reagan
found a middle ground that has suddenly
somehow been lost uh the middle ground
was called the Reagan Doctrine so the
Reagan Doctrine is that people must
fight for their own Freedom we don't
fight for them it's their country they
fight we help so the classic model of
this was the Soviets invade Afghanistan
they occupied with 100,000 troops
they're all these Afghan mujahid ID who
want to fight back Reagan's like I'm not
sending a single soldier but I'll send
some CIA advisors I'll give you some
Stinger Rockets to shoot down some
Soviet helicopters and and the beauty of
this was that it allowed that kind of
libertarian desire to have freedom
spread worldwide but without a kind of
costly deployment and extended
deployment of troops and then once the
Iraq war came along we went to
preemptive War we went to what did those
guys have to do with 9911 we went to the
idiotic you know where did that come out
of a store like if you if you break it
you own it what you know if you get rid
of a of a dictator of a country you now
have the job of rebuilding the country
what so all this kind of Madness this is
almost like neoconservatism gone berserk
but but Reagan was never on board with
any of this thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net